What up space cowboys.
Golzen here for AnimeUproar.
Today i have a new kind of video.
I was looking for a format similar to this
and then, I came across a JelloApocalypse video
and I loved the format and decided I definitely wanted
to give it a try by using anime i'm interested in
like My Hero Academia
I'll link JelloApocalyse's channel below
Check it out if you want to see video reviewing every
Disney movie or every Studio Ghibli movie
in 10 words or less. If you're new to this channel
don't forget to texas smash that subscribe button
and ring that youtube bell. Hunchback of Notre Dame style.
For more My Hero Academia videos.
Also feel free
to leave suggestions for future videos in the comments below.
The rules are as follow. I will go through all of
Class 1-A and explain every student in
10 words or less. I will also let you know who
my top 5 favourite characters are and
who my top 5 least favourite characters are.
Of course, these favourites will be beautifully subjective.
So, do not get 'triggered' if I think your waifu
is trash.
These are my opinions at the moment,
and they may well be subject to change as we
get more information about the character
I will also add some awards. Kinda like Best Jeanist
For the members of class 1-A just for fun.
Now, without further ado,
Lettuce Jam
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
And that is every class 1-A
student and their teacher explained
in 10 words or less
Now, I will go through my top 5 favourite class 1-A students
and my top 5 least favourite students.
Now, this is extremely hard because, there are so many
likeable characters in this class
but, i'm going to take a crack at it anyways.
My 5th favourite student is Bakugou. There is something I love about
Bakugou. He is unapologetically an asshole
almost all of the time. He stands out in a class
that's well behaved and has good manners for the most part.
With his cockyness
and his complete disregard seidel expectations for how
one should behave. He serves as a character foiled for
our protagonist who tends to be less confident more apologetic
but also nicer to those around him.
Bakugou is explosive in every way.
He stands out and he's never boring.
Furthermore, because he can so closed off when he does for a
friendship with Kirishima it is
all the more rewarding. He isn't a bad guy really.
That was proven when the League of Villains
unsuccessfully tried to turn him into one of them.
He is good at heart. He just speaks his mind
and refuses to play nice. There is something very
appealing about that. Especially because
that kind of behaviour is so rare among
his fellow students. My 4th favourite student
is Momo. She really is the whole package. She has
mad genius level intellect, an amazing quirk,
all the money in the world and yet she somehow
avoids the trap of being stuck up.
If anything one of her main
challenges is overcoming her own insecurities
and feelings of unworthiness.
To boot. She loves reading
which is probably my favourite pastime.
It also doesn't hurt that she is one of the best examples of
fan service done right in anime. Horikoshi
came up with the clever reason for her to be close to naked
all of the time and so
the fan service actually makes sense in the story and if it's
still wasn't blatantly obvious,
I am totally a fan of the service.
Can't save a bad show but, it can be the
perfect icing on the top of a good show,
and Momo makes for some quality icing.
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
My third favourite student goes by
many aliases including manly for all and
hard for all. He is the metapod of
Mha. He is Kirishima.
A manly man, overflowing with manliness.
I recently made a video 10 facts
you didn't know about Kirishima and in that video
I explained that Kirishima's evolution is my favourite thing about him
and I don't mean his evolution into a Butterfree.
Kirishima started out as a quiet kid
who didn't stand out and froze in the face of danger.
However, after being inspired
by people like Mina and his favourite
pro hero Crimson Riot. He decided that despite his
unflashy quirk, plain looking appearance and overwhelming
fear, he would change himself and become
a hero. (Kiri Lub) I love that his favourite hero is Crimson Riot and
not All Might, because it makes Kirishima
more original since at some point it seems like All Might
is everyone's favourite hero. So
his backstory was very refreshing for that reason. Furthermore
the fact that he wasn't born like Mina and Deku
and act without thinking when others are in trouble but
had to consciously change and improve himself also makes
him one of the most inspirational characters
in the show for me. He is a relatable character
and truly a great role model.
My second favourite character in the show and best girl of all
in my opinion.
Is Tsuyu. I said before that Momo was the the complete package but paradoxically her perfection holds her back from being even more likable.
Tsuyu is quirky. She is not what you'd expect
from a conventional best girl
and that's what I really love about her character. I gotta say
that I do not particularly like frogs in fact
they always kinda grossed me out so it's even more
impressive that Horikoshi made a frog like character
that I like as much as I do.
Her design is just unique and awesome in my opinion. She's
not the most talented person including socially
but like Kirishima she takes conscious
steps to overcome her weaknesses and make friends.
Where as Momo had a rich pampered upbringing
Tsuyu was taking care of her little siblings.
Tsuyu's life was never easy but she still remains a positive
person plus she's just like
the cutest thing ever and no one
can deny this. Next, my number one favourite
character is Sticky Balls
for all aka Mineta. (Get out)
Yes, the perverted man in diapers
is my favourite character. I like a lot of quote on quote
perverted characters in anime like Sanji from One Piece
and Jiraiya from Naruto. In the super pc
age we live in it's actually refreshing seeing
a dude so unashamedly
attracted to girls.
Yes, I know a lot of people hate Mineta but that only
makes me like him all the more.
In true all dudes have an inter pervert.
Including Horikoshi. Mineta is just more open about
it. Then some. So yes,
I believe that Mineta is the perverted hero
we all deserve. Know if that wasn't controversial
enough next i'm going to tread even
more dangerous territory I'm going to share my top 5 least
favourite characters. Before picking up your pitchforks
remember that this is just my subjective opinion.
If I happen to list one of your favourite characters
feel free to tell me why
you personally like them in the comments
and keep in mind that I don't hate these characters
I just prefer the others in
the class more. Now, may god help us
as I begin my trek across mine filled territory.
My 5th least favourite character is
the class President himself, Iida. (Grabs pitchfork)
I think his costume is pretty cool as so is his quirk.
But as a character he is kinda boring for me compared to
the the others in the class. He seems like a stand up
responsible guy who follows the rules. To be fair
this was complicated during the Stain Arc when
Iida chose to break the rules and go after Stain
to avenge his brother and when Iida
followed the others to go save Bakugou which is why he isn't
lower down on this list
but he quickly seems to revert back to his normal self
after these few rule breaking incidences. Even without
the Bakugou incident he did not want anyone to
go and only came along so he could get everyone out of there
if there was serious trouble. I much prefered
Kirishima's response for him there
was no question that he was gonna try to save his friend.
The rules be damned. In short
I think Iida is a great guy but,
that doesn't translate into an enjoyable character for me.
My 4th least favourite character is Sero. Sero
hasn't been fleshed out to much. He's an extra as
Bakugou would say, who is constantly smiling
his slightly unsettling smile. (His smile is beautiful) Besides
being a reference to spiderman, and
having similar powers, which is pretty cool,
Sero doesn't really stand out to me in any
significant way. I'm not crazy about his character design
and we don't know well
enough for me to care much about him at this point.
My 3rd least favourite character is Koda know again,
we have a guy with a quirk that I like, being
able to control animals has such badass potential
and Koda could one day grow into a
great hero and interesting character but he
has a ways to go. It doesn't help that the
sighting of the storying doesn't usually offer a wide selection of cool
animals for Koda to utilize nor does it
help that Koda die from a heart attack if he
ever watched Shino reck the sound ninja in
early Naruto. He's a shy dude. Who
doesn't stand out and hasn't gotten a lot of
screen time so far but, if he actually turned out
to be the U.A. traitor I might just have to re
evaluate my opinion about him. My
2nd least favourite character is Sato. Diabetes
for all is the muscle head of class 1-A.
Besides not being a great role model for kids,
his cognate(?) goes down when he's fighting
Meaning we probably can't expect to see
any interesting strategic fights from him in the future
and my least favourite character at the moment
is Ojiro the man with a tail.
Like I said he is a reference to Luke Skywalker and hopefully
that doesn't foreshadow All for One cutting off his tail but,
that reference does make me like him any
more, especially since i'm not personally
a huge fan of Star Wars to begin with. His design stands out
less then that of the previously mentioned characters
and he doesn't even provide some of the comedic potential
that Sato does. It also doesn't help that the most
significant thing he has done is get brainwashed
and that is it guys like I said these opinions
could change as we get more information about class 1-A but,
those are my thoughts at this time tell me who
your favourite and least favourite characters are in the comments below
and why if you guys enjoy this type of video and want to see more of them in the future definitely
Texas smash that like button and type 'Gozen Unleashed!' in the comments also
subscribe for more Mha content and use the quirk and
use the quirk of your choice to ring that magic bell
Again, this is the first time I made this kind of video
so I would really appreciate the feedback down below. Until next time.
Cya. Space Cowboys.
*Music*